[Music]
oh you think you know how to count
galaxy 5 6 7 8 9 10 20 whoops no not bad
this is the Samsung Galaxy S 20 but are
these models worth a nine phone leak
first things first
there are three new phones there's the
big Galaxy S 20 the bigger Galaxy S 20
plus and the even bigger Galaxy S 20
ultra the biggest improvements to the
whole line first
5g all three of the Android phones have
the faster connectivity that is if
you're in an area with coverage which
isn't many right now and second a whole
new camera system the phones have better
sensors zoom features a que video
recording with improved stabilization
night mode the list goes on they also
have OLED displays with integrated
fingerprint sensors and a generous 128
gigabytes of base storage oh and has
anyone seen the headphone port on here
have you seen it
anyone know headphone port yeah it's
gone so which one do you pick the
differences come in screen size and
cameras let's start smallish the galaxy
s 20 has a 6.2 inch screen and three
cameras on the back
I couldn't test the camera quality in
the short demo time but I did get to
test one of the new awesome features
that's on all three phones this is a
Samsung Galaxy S 20 this is a juggler
what's your name your name is blue BL UE
press the button and the AI driven
feature captures the scene in both
Stills and video at the same time you
don't have to think about choosing one
or the other that's capturing meaningful
moments this is so meaningful to me then
you can see the different videos and
photos the systems take it this is this
is the best shot which it is a really
good shot I'm a really good photographer
and this is a little video which is not
moving on up the galaxy has 20 plus with
an even bigger six point seven inch
screen in addition to those three
cameras on the standard s 20 this one
has a time-of-flight camera it captures
depth information for augmented reality
applications those too small for you
that's why there's the galaxy as 20
altra and it's whopping six point nine
inch screen and crazy camera system this
one's got a one hundred and eight
megapixel wide camera a 12 megapixel
ultra wide camera and this 48 megapixel
telephoto the real trick is in the last
one which has a folded zoom and a prism
to refract light it has a 10x optical
zoom and a hundred X digital zoom option
I tried it out and it was pretty crazy
and potentially creepy spending 13 feet
away from this notepad I could snap this
shot and read that tiny handwriting
ultra also has a 40 megapixel selfie cam
which is great for seeing if you need to
tweeze your eyebrows or nose hair so I
did the math and if you bought all three
of these phones to base models would
cost you together $3,600 the s20 starts
at $1000 the s20 plus at $1,200 and the
ultra at $1,400 Samson is dropping the
price on last year's models the Galaxy S
10 mine now starts at $600
yes the galaxy has 20 looks promising
and expensive but I'll need a bit more
time with them to see if it really
should have been the galaxy s 11